bonjour et bien ce soir lorsqu'il sera
19h à paris il sera 10 heures du matin à
san francisco monsieur georges pompidou
quittera alors cette ville pour prendre
le chemin de chicago à chicago il doit
notamment recevoir un groupe
d'architectes et d'urbanisme
d'urbanistes pardon une délégation de
l'alliance française la journée devant
se terminer par un dîner officiel mais
nous allons revenir sur cette journée
d'hier journée qui a surtout été marquée
par un discours sur la jeunesse à
l'université de stanford george peter f
en fait nous revenons un peu plus loin
en arrière
oui avec les images du départ du
président pompidou de cap kennedy que
vous voyez ici
cela se passait jeudi dernier le
reportage est arrivé ici il ya quelques
heures seulement c'est pourquoi nous
l'avons programmé aujourd'hui à midi
normalement nul n'est autorisé à
pénétrer sur ses terres c'est donc un
honneur exceptionnel accordé au
président de la république il a pris
l'ascenseur il est monté en haut des
structures des échafaudages qui entoure
la fusée et la cabine apollo xiii qui
d'ici un mois et demi prendra le chemin
de la lune normalement nul n'est
autorisé à berrechid sur ces lieux à
l'exception des cosmonautes de même je
croyais qu'on lui avait remis un casque
à sonnerie est faible en gros si on l'a
vu au tout début de ce film vous avez vu
georges pompidou president flore
extrêmement impressionné par l'ampleur
des moyens la capacité des techniciens
et l'organisation produits
et puis aussi par la simplicité et
modestie le naturel de tous ceux qui
participent à ce magnifique travail et
qui ont l'air de trouver cela tout
naturel il me reste à souhaiter que ce
soit pour le bien de tous les hommes
et puis quinze jours nous aussi les
européens nous puissions aller dans la
lune et voici quelques heures plus tard
l'arrivée à san francisco était jeudi
soir prendre du matin heure de paris
puisqu'il y a neuf heures de décalage
entre paris et san francisco
j'ai profité aux va être reçue par le
maire de san francisco monsieur josette
alioto
mr president 20 pts sur le stand with
casting à quelques mots de bienvenue du
maire monsieur alioto monsieur le
président il madame pompidou vous êtes
ici les très bienvenus
il rappelle que la france est le plus
vieil âne - la plus vieille annie le
plus ancien allié des états unis et en
signant gage d'amitié il va remettre
dans l'instant la clé on ne sait pas si
sa visité en or mais c'est une clé la
clé de la ville de st francis trees
l'agression voici le symbole dit il de
notre esprit ns rustine que nous avons
pour vous
monsieur le maire je vous remercie tout
d'abord en mon nom et au nom de mon
épouse au nom des personnalités qui
m'accompagne en particulier du mr
affaires étrangères madame simonet pour
vos aimables paroles et plus encore pour
cette clé de la ville de san francisco
que vous m'avez remise et dans laquelle
je vois à la fois un symbole et je
trouverai un souvenir qui me sera
précieux je suis particulièrement
heureux de me trouver ce soir à san
francisco je suis encore jamais venu
d'abord parce que je sais que je vais
ainsi visiter une des plus belles villes
des états unis est une de celles de
raboter la plus réputée dans le monde
entier
ensuite monsieur le maire vous êtes ici
au sein de cet état de californie où à
l'heure actuelle se développe une
activité et une expansion dans tous les
domaines qui en font un des centres les
plus actifs et les plus remarquables de
ce grand pays
merci encore mille fois de cet accueil
qui nous touche infiniment et vive san
francisco et vive l'amitié entre la
france et les états unis
nous passons maintenant à vendre à la
journée d'hier c'est ça et bien vendredi
matin le président de la république a
visité l'université de standford et
notamment l'accélérateur linéaire de
stanford qui est très célèbre
à l'arrivée il ya eu des manifestations
très pacifique il faut dire
manifestations d'étudiants pro israélien
tenus à l'écart par d'impressionnantes
forces de police équipées de matraques
et de lance grenades
on peut lire sur les pancartes la paix
n'est pas un mirage vendez vos mirage à
israël et cetera un peu plus tard dans
la journée d'ailleurs à san francisco
même une centaine de manifestants arabes
ou de sympathisants pro arabe ont
participé à une autre contre
manifestation pourrait-on dire disant
pompidou nous sommes avec vous à
l'université le président de la
république s'est entretenu avec des
personnalités scientifiques des
professeurs tout en visitant
l'accélérateur qui sert à l'étude de la
matière
puis retour à san francisco des jeunes
et au commonwealth club où il rencontre
monsieur ronald reagan gouverneur de la
californie
le déjeuner se déroule dans une ambiance
très détendue et dans 7 après qu'il y a
eu ce discours dont on parle tant on a
fait ou le président pompidou a fait
surtout allusion à la jeunesse et aux
problèmes de la jeunesse où il a parlé
de crise de civilisation
revenant sur les journées de sur les
journées de mai 1968
monsieur pompidou a reconnu que la
jeunesse et la société toute entière
souffrait d'un malaise profond at il dit
il cite alors baudelaire qu'est ce que
le monde a désormais affaire sous le
ciel il dit qu'il s'agit de donner un
sens à la civilisation urbaine et
technique dans laquelle nous sommes
inexorablement engagé selon le président
la solution n'est ni dans une seule
philosophie du désespoir ni dans une
destruction pure et simple
ni même dans ce qu'il appelle mené au
marxisme selon monsieur pompidou notre
devoir est d'ouvrir les yeux sur le
présent de s'interroger sur l'avenir de
lutter contre la justice injustice dit
il partout présentes dans les sociétés
évoluées comme dans les pays sous
développés
monsieur pompidou a aussi parlé du
marché commun répondant à une question
d'ailleurs il a déclaré que l'entrée de
la grande-bretagne dans le marché commun
dépend des dents définitives du
gouvernement britannique lui même mais
il a dit je pense que nous aboutirons à
un accord et si j'avais un pari
d'affaires je le ferai sur cet accord il
san francisco est également certain
nombre de manifestations par organisé
par la communauté juive et monsieur
pompidou a reçu 14 personnes de l'une de
ces communautés
effectivement l'entretien a duré 45
minutes et le porte parole de cette
communauté qui était monsieur goldberg
l'ancien ambassadeur des états unis aux
nations unies a déclaré qu'il n'avait
pas aucune raison de douter de la
sincérité de monsieur pompidou lorsque
le président de la république affirme
qu'il souhaite instaurer contribuer à
l'instauration de la paix au moyen
orient mais monsieur goldberg dit je ne
suis pas d'accord sur les moyens
qu'envisage monsieur pur bijou pour
ramener la paix au moyen-orient bien
aujourd'hui nous vous l'avons dit la
prochaine étape c'est chicago
nous suivrons donc dès ce soir ce départ
pour chicago
une dépêche car nous revenons maintenant
aux informations de france et se plie
pas d'une dépêche mais un communiqué qu
on me demande de vous lire on recherche
un camion bedford bleus marqués
transport drouhin arènes numéro
d'immatriculation 85,02 kiev 44 ce
camion a quitté rennes ce matin à 3
heures 45 avec les actions de la vis
imprimé cette nuit et le camion a
disparu avec son chargement il est
probablement en panne où il a eu un
accident
pour tous les renseignements concernant
ce camion vous êtes priés gentiment de
téléphoner à ce numéro 704 46 71
je répète 706 704 46 71 ou 704 46 72
je répète 704 46,72 pouvez même
éventuellement téléphoner en pc en
france les inondations sont toujours
préoccupante notamment dans la région
parisienne de la scène continue à monter
aussi bien dans la capitale que dans les
localités de la banlieue
ce matin à paris au pont de la tournelle
la scène atteignait 5 mètres 50
et l'on prévoit que le 5 mars et le 4 à
6 mètres soit un mètre soixante dix de
plus que la cote d' alerte à conflans
sainte honorine 300 personnes des
quartiers de la ville basse ont dû être
évacuée d'urgence par la municipalité
qui les arts au logis provisoirement
dans l'oise des inondations prennent une
certaine ampleur les crue de la saône
du doubs se sont poursuivies vendredi on
s'attend à l'inondation de certaines
rues et de la nationale 6 à la sortie
nord de mâcon dans la région d'angers la
montée des eaux de la loire s'est
ralenti la crue de la meuse a atteint 1
point maximum vendredi à charleville
mézières et nous allons maintenant
regarder poursuivant notre tour de
france ce qui se passe un rochefort sur
loire
cette année encore la loire et ses
affluents sont sortis de leur lit
la culture les prairies les terrains de
camping ne sont plus qu'une vaste
étendue d'eau des peupliers qui bordent
les routes sont les seuls repères qui
permettent de regagner les villages
isolés à bord de larges barques à fond
plat
cette situation n'a rien d'exceptionnel
des habitants ils sont habitués depuis
leur naissance
comme on vous le dira ceux de la
chapelle près de rochefort sur loire
monsieur ça fait combien de temps que
vous êtes isolé isolé il ya trois
semaines environ il repose une dame à
quoi et ça fait longtemps que vous
habitez dans la vallée à 47 ans survenu
monde ici tous les ans vous avez de
l'eau ou presque tous les ans mais là
deux ans elle est venue jusque couperet
de la maison quoi il arrive que la
maison soit inondée haddaoui mois trois
fois les pico des mariés depuis 47
qu'est ce que vous faites à ce moment là
bas on essaye de mettre des mots dessus
des madriers ou de se lever sa hausse au
niveau quoi aider et crochets et des
cordes
qu'est ce que vous faites pour le
ravitaillement bas on prend le bateau
et puis on va au bourg mener les mets
les gosses à l'école et puis il ramenait
ce qu'on a besoin quoi mesdames ça fait
combien de temps que vous habitez dans
la région 14
et vous madame chose en 13 ans vous êtes
donc habitués aux inondations oui parce
que tous les ans alors rien n'est pas
dans les mêlant maillaud l'a201 qu'elle
y était déjà venu c'est pas exceptionnel
non vous êtes habités comment faites
vous quand vous voyez l'eau arrive et
vous voyez on monte tous les lits les
armoiries q3 partout pour débarrasser
pour que les menottes pas d'en haut
et vous où le gvt ou alors dans une
chambre où tu veux avoir des problèmes
de ravitaillement bas les voisins qui ne
les apports il nous a pourtant avait
tellement au point de vue chauffage d'un
petit peu de charbon et du bois non
moins comme ça vous attendez la décrue
oui en cadeau de patience dont il est un
ancien mannequin on est là pour combien
de temps pensez vous qu'elle va arriver
mais je pense
leicester pour demain ce jugement est ce
qu'on peut dire ce que cette
conversation est empreinte de fatalisme
et peut-être aussi disons de bonne
humeur contre l'information de france à
montpellier les 28 personnes qui avaient
été interpellés hier après midi à la
suite des incidents qui a accompagné la
manifestation des viticulteurs vont être
remises devaient être remises en liberté
dans la matinée après examen de leur
situation
aucun viticulteurs ne se trouve chez ses
vingt-huit personnes parmi lesquelles on
compte un grand nombre d'étudiants en
lettres une autre dépêche de ce matin
quatre commerçants ont été arrêtés hier
soir et la nuit dernière à lyon à la
suite d'un vol de 2500 détonateur dans
une carrière d environ au cours de la
nuit de jeudi à vendredi
tous les détonateurs ont été récupérés
les identités des quatre personnes n'ont
pas effet révélé de l'étranger on
apprend ce matin que le directeur de la
métro goldwin meyer à beyrouth monsieur
edouard sassoon a été assassiné à son
bureau
monsieur sassoon était juif on ne sait
encore si cet assassinat est à mettre au
dossier du conflit israélo arabe
par ailleurs des frictions continue
entre israéliens et libanais quatre
civils libanais dont l'un était armé
d'un fusil ont été arrêtés en territoire
israélien au guatemala le ministre des
affaires étrangères monsieur alberto
fuentes mort a été enlevé par des
membres des forces armées
révolutionnaires de tendance maoïstes
ils ont donné 24 heures au gouvernement
pour échanger le ministre des affaires
étrangères contre un jeune étudiant de
24 ans shiren calvillo l'un des leaders
de ce groupe maoïste arrêtés récemment
les forces armées révolutionnaires
menace d'exécuter
le ministre si leurs exigences ne sont
pas satisfaites
voilà pour le dossier politique
maintenant je crois que nous entamons un
dossier des sports importante parce que
ce samedi oui c'est à midi il y a deux
aux activités sportives au cours du
week-end d'abord aux états unis il faut
rappeler les résultats a les bons
résultats des français à vancouver plus
tôt au canada c'est alain penske a
triomphé chez les hommes dans le slalom
géant hier devant blair l'autrichien
troisième bruxelles 4e pichot heures et
cinquième jeux comme si vous remarquerez
que et emmené crucell et troisième
échelons de 5e ils n'ont marqué tous les
deux eu aucun point au classement de la
coupe du monde ce qui fait que l'écart
qui sépare les deux hommes est toujours
le même sens 46 points proche rendre 140
pour patrick roussel à égalité de points
avec tony
la compétition se poursuit chez les
dames encore une victoire de
l'imbattable michel jacquot devant
barbara cochrane et judy nagl michel
jacquot est évidemment en tête avec un
maximum de points de la coupe du monde
et on pense pas qu'elle puisse
maintenant être rattrapé puis je vous
propose de voir des images de ce qui
maintenant en france c'était à chamonix
ce matin sur la piste des houches une
piste longue de 3200 mètres et est une
course importante car elle compte pour
la coupe du monde de ski catégorie b
c'est à dire que le vainqueur j'espère
que nous allons voir les images d'un
temps le vainqueur de cette course à 13
points qui lui permettront peut-être
l'an prochain de passer en série a et
voici le premier justement il s'agit de
rudy seller le frère du célèbre toni
sailer triple champion olympique à
cortina d'ampezzo vous souvenez c'était
en 1956 au lycée de l'air c'est la
graine de champion deux minutes 13
secondes 61 centièmes pour ses 3200
mètres et des bons surtout dans le
schuss final assez remarquée rire les
français ne se sont pas très bien
comporté dans cette descente si
l'arrivée des salaires il s'apercevra
également que son dossard s'est quelque
peu décroché ou comme indécente ce qui
le fait perdre quelques centièmes de
seconde il bat le record de la piste qui
était détenu en 1969 par le monsieur
vous allez voir descendre maintenant
courte ou glaire un suisse en 2 minutes
16 secondes 81 centièmes ou guerre est
parti il a déjà réalisé le meilleur
temps à mi parcours il va terminer
deuxième aujourd'hui avec lui aussi un
dos tard quelque peu d'effet donc on
perd dans quelques autres centièmes de
seconde
les français sont très loin troisième
bernard gros filet à 2 secondes et 34
centièmes quatrième single je suis 5e et
nexter l'autrichien les autres français
sont rossat-mignod 8e et jean pierre
oger
m mais regardez septe descendre ces
derniers mètres de haut ou glaire
deuxième aujourd'hui à chamonix derrière
c'est l'air il se rattrape en
catastrophe
lapointe arrière du ski a touché la
neige pensons avec la vitesse j'ai
réussi à rétablir l'équilibré ou guerre
deuxième assez loin il faut dire de rudy
seiler à 96 centièmes exactement il
termine sur les talons moyenne près de
87 km heure pour le vainqueur c'est
l'air maintenant d'autres événements
sportifs en particulier le rugby et cela
nous concerne car il s'agit du tournoi
des cinq nations il ya deux rencontres
aujourd'hui l'une à dublin irlande
contre l'ecosse et l'autre l'angleterre
à twickenham contre le pays de galles
vous pourrez suivre d'ailleurs sur la
deuxième chaîne à partir de 14h55 le
reportage que la première la deuxième
chaîne nous offre donc avec des
commentaires de christian ory 14h55 en
coupe de france et là les
téléspectateurs sont intéressés aussi à
15 heures ils pourront suivre strasbourg
nantes 16e de finale de la coupe de
france c'est la seule rencontre prévue
aujourd'hui commenté par michel bret sur
la première chaîne à 15 heures les
résultats des championnats indoor des
etats-unis c'est-à-dire des courses en
salle avec un étonnant garçon il s'agit
de martigues mcgrady veut dire que la
distance sur laquelle il ou de cours est
quelque peu bâtarde 600 yard ce n'est
pas une licence reconnu en tout cas il
bat à chaque fois il vit evans qui est
l'un des meilleurs coureurs sur 400 m
haies puis il arrive aussi de battre
ralph du bel le
l'australien qui est champion olympique
du 800 m martin mcgrady a réussi une
minute 7 secondes 6/10 aussi sa
meilleure performance mondiale
et puis un acteur que vous connaissez
vous l'avez peut-être vu dans l'élite
il s'agit mais oui de steve mcqueen et
bien steve mcqueen va prendre le volant
d'une porsche 917 associé à jackie
stewart champion du monde aux prochaines
24 heures du mans la nouvelle est
officielle et on pense aussi que steve
mcqueen va réaliser à ce sujet au sujet
des 24 heures un court métrage soit long
métrage qu'il prépare depuis déjà un ou
deux ans enfin il est bon de terminer
sur des images de judo car c'était de
l'actualité hier soir à saint-pierre
part donc dans la salle pierre de
coubertin
la deuxième rencontre contre la hongrie
mercredi déjà la france avait triomphé
par 14 victoires à 2 les judokas
français ont été quelque peu accroché
beaucoup plus en tout cas que mercredi
hier soir à paris et ils ont triomphé
par 12 victoires à 6 la résistance
hongroise suis beaucoup plus importante
que mercredi dernier chez nous
représentants catégorie léger pili prix
on leva ses deux combats et le grand
limite à en catégorie mi moyens
finalement 12 à 6 pour la france et le
lourd vivier a triomphé deux fois par
ippon sur le tatami du stade parisien
bond et je crois que je regardais
disparités petit dossier sur votre teint
je crois que maintenant après avoir bien
accaparé l'écran peut le rendre à jacky
alexandre la société nationale des
beaux-arts créé par meissonnier va fêter
son 80e anniversaire
aux halles nous allons suivre un
reportage de jean pierre guérie en
construisant ce pavillon des halles où
il n'y a pas si longtemps encore se vend
des poissons et fromages baltard ne
pouvait sans doute pas imaginé qu'il
deviendrait un jour un centre d'art
premier salon à soutenir celui de la
société nationale des beaux-arts son
président françois boulay nous a raconté
comment les exposants avaient tous mis
la main à la pâte pour transformer un
lugubre sous sol en une claire salle
d'exposition ultime hommage
il l'a fait devant cette sculpture des
raymond subes morts cette année d'un
accident en somme vous avez voulu
prouver qu'on n'était pas seulement des
peintres des sculpteurs mai
être si de temps en temps lorsqu'il le
fallait des électriciens des décorateurs
des menuisiers
nous venons d'avoir un très gros travail
pour installer ces nouvelles salles
d'exposition que l'on souhaitait voir
animer sur le plan culturel le quartier
des halles nous avons réuni un certain
nombre d'artistes qui sont venus
bénévolement et à titre volontaire pour
travailler sur place et ils ont passé
près d'un mois à travailler ici vous
défendre et quand même une idée
oui nous le défendons une idée qui
consiste à penser que la peinture
continue à évoluer à l'intérieur de la
figuratif nous sommes dans l'ensemble
des artistes figuratifs ou des artistes
de synthèse et nous pensons que dans la
peinture actuelle ceci c'est par là qui
constitue la suite de la véritable
peinture comme pour prouver l'importance
qu'il s'efforce de lui accorder le salon
s'ouvre par la salle des sculptures
c'est d'abord un hommage à quillivic cet
ancien pêcheur breton devenu l'un de nos
sculpteurs les plus doués qui est morte
récemment l'âge de 90 ans
un nu aux formes opulentes de georges
riguet
prix pubis dechavanne vivier rno expose
les liteaux évocatrice qu'il a créé pour
illustrer l'univers sans limite
herwig aux passionnés de fleurs des
tropiques
c'est en rendre tout le mystère
doit-elle lui trouve son inspiration
dans les paysages de seine et marne
suprenant hélas si menacée de jean
rigaud un trouville tout frémissant de
lumière une demeure romantique comme
maurice buffet imaginer enserrée dans
son parc comme par des lianes un bouquet
sans faille et sans reproche de caillots
jean pierre alaux enfin unis le
fantastique à la réalité pour engendrer
la poésie quittons les beaux-arts pour
parler d'un homme de théâtre tous les
amis de jacques fabbri se demande ce
qu'il devient il ne fait plus de théâtre
et bien sachez qu'ils passent maintenant
dans un cabaret parisien
ceci pour diverses raisons qu'il va nous
dévoiler maintenant aux côtés de théo
sarapo et d'annie cordy jacques fabbri
vient de débuter à la tête de l'art cet
aventurier du spectacle tellement
amoureux de la liberté qu'il a voulu
toujours produire ses spectacles
lui-même se trouve une nouvelle fois
robinet il a suffi de l'échec des deux
orphelines pour engloutir tout l'argent
que lui avait rapporté ses succès
précédents
avant ce malheur je produisais tous mes
spectacles avec quelquefois un associé
et c'est toujours une aventure
extrêmement périlleuse parce que dès que
ça ne marche pas on est endetté pour 7 8
ans j'ai remboursé en 66 des dettes
contractées en 57
non c'est assez dangereux si on ne scie
on ne fait pas ce métier de production
de spectacles dans une optique
commerciale et comme je n'ai pas du tout
une mentalité commerciale belge était
toujours en danger de mort j'ai beaucoup
plus peur pour mes 25 minutes en scène
que pour une générale devant le
tout-paris comment pourquoi est ce le
fait d'être l'auteur c'est parce que
j'aimerais vous vous gagnez vous perdez
tout de suite j'ai rencontré dans le
pays catalan à un bon ami à moi qui ai
un jour on a donné un petit bout de
papier sur lequel il avait le texte
qu'ils avaient marché dans un bistrot
comme ça c'était l'histoire d'un type
qui veut qu'elle sa femme interdisait
gloire du whisky et qui dit vie des ces
bouteilles dans l'évier c'était écrit
d'une manière tellement drôle est
complètement absurde et fou que je suis
dur mais j'ai essayé de dire ça au
cabaret voici ce qui arrive j'enlevais
le bouchon de la première bouteille et
j'envie des le contenu dans l'évier sauf
un plein vers que j'ai bu extirpait le
bouchon de la deuxième bouteille et
jean-phi autant c'est à dire que je vis
des la bouteille dans l'évier sauf un
plat vers que j'ai bu
j'arrachais le bouchon de la 4è
bouteille et jambu le contenu à
l'exception d'un plein vers que je
vidais dans l'évier j'arrachais le
bouchon du cinquième évier et je vidais
la bouteille dans le vert que je but
j'ai acheté une bouteille au bouchon de
la suivante les jambes eu un plein évier
mais je vis d'elle restant dans la
bouteille
je sortis du vers le 7e évier je vidais
la bouteille dans le vert que je but
lorsque jus tout vidé je me mis à calais
le mur de ma maison et a compté les
bouteilles et les verts et voilà que
j'en trouvais 29 pourrait être
absolument sûr je me mis à les raconter
au passage et voilà que j'en trouvais 79
mais lorsque la maison revint à passer
je les compte est une troisième fois je
m'aperçus enfin que j'avais retrouvé le
compte de toutes les maisons de toutes
les bouteilles d'eau tous les bouchons
de tous les verres à l'exception d'un
évier et d'une maison que je but si
jacques fabbri si jacques fabbri ne sait
plus très bien vu où il emmenait les
grands couturiers ne savent pas eux
comment leur nouvelle mode va être
apprécié reçu par le public
vous avez qu'hier c'était le grand jour
de la haute couture les modèles ont été
présentés
vous avez déjà pu suivre une première
partie du reportage dix islamistes
d'ailleurs suivre aujourd'hui
la suite et la fin de ce reportage
réalisé par bernard de flandre
on en parle depuis hier la mode
printemps été a misé sur la longueur
avec préférence pour la jupe au mollet
les audacieux ont fait leurs collections
sur le thème du couple déjà vu
l'ensemble pantalons plus difficile a
adopté la robe à 20 cm du sol pour lui
comme pour elle
à
ans
h
enfin
c'était qu'un reportage où les images
étaient d'alain petiet nos prochaines
d'information à 18 heures cinquante
mille avesnoise m messieurs
bonne journée à demain